Gary Spicer thank you so much for coming
on for anyone that doesn't know Gary
Spicer he is my pasta and we've known
each other now for jeez only like maybe
seven maybe seven years now and yeah yes
mentored me kept me accountable and also
taught me a lot about business so I'll
let you kind of give a little bit back
story Gary but you I know you've managed
hundreds and hundreds of people a lot of
staff you now need a church in Coventry
why don't you just give a little
background to who you are and then we
can start getting some advice during
this time and give people some practical
wisdom yeah thanks so much thanks for
having me on
well my name's Gary spice if you already
said I've been a pastor of a church for
25 years I've also led schools with
around about 400 staff and about 3,000
student so I did that for nearly 10
years and they would deprive schools
that we try to endeavor to turn around
and make successful which in Ofsted's
terms we did so that was really good and
obviously bring more positivity and
aspiration to the students and the
families and then I run another trust as
well which really is training and
Commission entrepreneurs and people who
want to make a difference in pioneer in
either business social enterprise and
just making a difference in people's
lives and I think that's really where we
met actually and I have a number of
staff on that trust as well so I run
three trusts including the church each
having their own staff and great people
around me and myself and you've met as
he said about seven years ago I think it
was we met initially after an event and
we talked a little about the Lions which
obviously I was running at that time and
then you came on the Lions which was
part of our program of helping
entrepreneurs and pioneers you know
pioneers something successful in
business and also grow their business to
the success which you know you have been
a trailblazer in doing that Samuel and
always been proud of you well done I
really appreciate that and one of the
very I guess strange things about you is
you're kind of a business a business
advisor to me but then also you advise
me on other areas personal life
spiritual so really someone that I speak
to a lot in times of difficulty if I'm
making it
decision and how's this crisis right now
that we're in how is it affected you
personally and also your organization's
well from a school point of view
obviously the schools have closed down
so we have furloughed some staff that go
into the schools and do families not
family support but some youth work but
we've kept a number of the staff on as
well working with families and young
people because we're very pastoral and
that we want to help
obviously families in need at this time
so everything really for me is managed
from home I am now working from home
totally as a church pastor you know zoom
calls and phone calls and FaceTime are
at the new norm and helping people in
crisis I am finding that a lot of people
are helping each other and encouraging
each other which is really encouraging
but we're also putting material out
we're now recording services online so
that's a new medium of communication for
us on the whole as a church and it's
excited because we're reaching a new
audience and I think that's exciting and
it's been really good I've been able to
reconnect because you're my pastor and I
still see you as my pastor and Coventry
church and mosaic Church kind of all
always probably will fill up my
spiritual home but now live in near
London in Buckinghamshire
it's been great been able to reconnect
and do some of the what do you call it
virtual virtual church services because
my local church is closed so that's been
really really helpful what would you say
to people and more holistically speaking
because this time that we're in I mean
I'm going to talk a little about
business asking questions about how to
survive as a business person but from
from a mental health perspective I mean
for me I'm very blessed and very
fortunate that I've got a nice garden
and it's been the weather's being cry
I've got a family who are very very easy
to be around who I love lots but I mean
for some people they're in apartments
though in flats they're on their own
there might be in in a household where
they don't get on well with their family
or their spouse and that's not just
gonna be the case for some people that's
gonna be the case for a lot of people
and even if you do love your family not
been able to see friends not been able
to see your general family
don't live in the same household it's
really tough I mean for me and I feel
like I've got a little bit of an
obligation and responsibility to my to
my followers and people I'm not running
events right now I'm here my YouTube
channel but I really want to display our
message of positivity and hope to to my
audience and also give some practical
advice and I thought maybe I'd ask you
this question how can we sustain our
mental well-being peace of mind during
this very difficult time right now well
I think you know it's a great question
and as you said many different people
have different contexts and if you live
in a place where you've got space I
think first of all that's probably
easier and also resource but there are a
lot of people who I'm actually working
with who don't have space don't have a
lot of resource and there is a real
struggle you know sometimes single
parents with you know three or four kids
for example and trying to do
homeschooling and then trying to get the
groceries and you know trying to keep
kids occupied I think the first thing
that we have to do whether we're a
parent leader business leader is be
disciplined create a new routine which
creates a new rhythm
I think routine is the first thing
discipline routine and rhythm then gives
them a mentum for us to have a bit of a
new normal
now I don't think this new normal we're
in will stay I think it will be a new
new normal if I can put it like that
but we've got to make a transition to
that by not just staying as we were and
I think if we just stay as we were then
I think it does affects our mental
affects our emotional and spiritual
well-being and ultimately then our
relational well-being with those who we
may genuinely love but become frustrated
with and of course I've been married 35
years now some little longer than you
but in that side of things you know
obviously I'm seeing my wife every day
every hour and you know in one place you
think isn't that wonderful but there are
some times where we don't argue but we
do have a few intense discussions and in
those moments we've got to learn how we
can give each other space even just
within the home and just understand that
we are in this new normal so I think
discipline you know getting up at a
certain time still you know being able
to have a routine which says I'm going
to do this piece of work I'm going to do
this with my family
I'm going to do this for myself even if
it's reading or self-study or going
online it's really important I think
those who don't create that it can
create a more a mindful wander and if
our mind wanders too much and we give it
too much space without routine then I
think that's where mental illness can
kick in a little bit as well and also to
be fair to people those who may feel
very fearful about this situation I just
want to say it is only for a season we
will come through this but how we come
through is important even individually I
think if we do the right things in this
period we can come through stronger and
in a cheap more in life yeah that's
great I really appreciate that and I
think I grew routines really born me and
my family have been really getting into
a good routine helmet working out
spending time you know thinking
strategizing what do you think because I
know you're quite humble you do advise a
lot of you know large business large
business their owners um do you think
that this is all bad do you think that
there's any opportunities from an
economic performance camera I will say
is I've got a post up on my social media
about some of the opportunities that I
believe this is creating and also the
opportunity not only to make money but
also to be productive and to be
disciplined and to read books and to
learn educate ourselves and I think
there was a few people that were
actually almost offended by the post
because in their mind they're saying
actually we don't want to thrive in this
we just want to survive for this we've
got kids with maybe and you're talking
about making money and opportunities so
I want to be sensitive to anyone that
there might be really struggling but I
can't help it but you know say well I
think you know thriving isn't just about
money but we you know if we we've got a
survival mentality then that's how we
come out of it and I don't think then
we've got a springboard to thrive and I
think you know we can find ourselves and
we know that every time of pressure
whether it be war which we kind of in at
the moment but pandemic war actually
produces pressure but in pressure it
produces innovation appreciates and
produces new ideas and new vision so I
do think as much as we may feel we're in
a prison I would term it we're in an ink
and I think we've got to look at our
time that we're in right now not as a
prison of restriction but an incubator
where we can birth new ideas that we may
not be able to fulfill right now but boy
are we ready to go when we get out of it
and I think that way we can thrive in
wordly and if we can thrive in wordly
we're definitely going to thrive
outwardly and money and prosperity and
blessing as I would call it will just
come of that I think also Samuel you
know it's very important to know where
we anchor our lives I'm a Christian
minister and as you know and I do
believe that what helps me is my
Christian faith you know that when I
read the Bible I understand that this is
a season it's not the end I also know
you know that the next days however long
but they are you know I mean God's hands
and that really helps me keep a
stability a spiritual stability that
helps me keep an emotional stability and
a positive view of the future and so I
believe people came a positive view
without God but he definitely helps us
thrive and whether it's making money or
whatever I do see people need system as
an incubator not a prison or confinement
time mmm that's really powerful and I
think I mean I I totally agree about
having having a faith it helps others
some bad situations over the years I've
been in a bit in problems and you throw
me up how you doing and although the
circumstances might not be great right
now I've always said yeah I'm okay
because you know I've got a relationship
with God and I I know I know that what
happens right now you come into this
world with nothing you leave with
nothing in between well you know we all
go a lot we all have seasons and as you
know my family too you know only what 15
months ago you know we have to shop news
of our 28 year old son who's we love
dearly suddenly have a seizure and be
diagnosed with two brain tumors you know
they would dark days and in those dark
days you get to know who you are
as much as how you respond and I do feel
that at times like that and people may
feel in dark days listen to this now
whether it's business or life or
relationship you know they may feel it's
just a dark day they can't see the end
of the tunnel but in those moments I've
got to say faith in God really helps me
and I'm not just saying it cuz I'm a
minister
you know I'm you know I'm a little older
than you a lot older than you but in
those journeys and the journey we had
with our son he did come for it as you
know but there was some really dark days
or some dark days in hotels and some
dark days on planes with dark days when
I was there by the surgery and just
waiting for him to come round and you
asked a lot of questions like I'm sure a
lot of your listeners are asking right
now you know they never expected this
it's the unexpected but in the
unexpected we've got an O'Mara rancorous
and you know for me my faith is an
anchor and out of that faith it helps me
discipline put a routine in get a new
rhythm you know and then we start to
thrive yeah that's great
what would you say because I mean even
from from my perspective I know we spoke
because you you helped me on the charity
side of things so we've got we've got
projects going on in Africa we were just
about to start some school works
building up some schools in Uganda and
then this happened so now it's like okay
well our build was even working
we went we're more reserved and careful
now with finances and I know you've
encouraged me used actually sometimes
when you've got a lot it's easy to give
but when you're like oh geez what's
going to happen next month because I on
my property business now things were
going to swimmingly Wow and not to say
they're going back now but it's it makes
you think geez what's gonna happen if
this happens or if value is undervalued
properties or if and suddenly you you do
feel slightly out of control you do feel
yeah okay what's going to happen and you
said to me actually when you can
continue giving through that it's almost
an even more beautiful thing what did
you what did you mean by that
well I wanna say to be able thing I
think you know Tom's like this our
values are tested so you know for me
giving is a value it's not just a habit
and values stick through good and bad
man I accept you know amounts can change
and different things because figures
change even in business but I think if
helping others generosity and giving is
a value I don't care what season it is
we should continue with it I think it's
a great base for our soul it's a great
base for you know winning the influence
in people and just showing people our
genuineness
is not just what we can get but what we
can give to this life and I think great
business people you know they always
want to make a difference in people's
lives ultimately they want to see people
be blessed they want to see people
better whether they're selling a product
or they giving a service you know and as
a church minister as a school leader I
want to see people better themselves
well that doesn't change in bad times it
may have the way I do it change so for
example you know my daughter she's
furloughed and she works for a company
and you know we live on a small estate
and I'm running food banks and feeding
people and trying to help and she got up
one more set that I want to help she's
19 and I said what you want to do she
says I'm gonna push a handwritten note
through everyone's door in our state and
then put a box outside our house and
just say could you donate a few tins to
the food bank in Coventry we were unand
inundated with people knock in the door
not only did we go I mean obviously we
did the social distance then but in the
midst of talking with them it didn't
just get we didn't get tuna beans
we got a conversation we actually built
a relationship in fact I would say in
our state now there's business I can do
with these people in the future not that
we ever set out to do that but by giving
it connected us and it was a value
connection of giving to others and I
just want to encourage people in
business and whatever they leave right
now
but you know don't compromise your
values in terms of this because it's
your values that keep you steady and see
you through and and that's really what I
was talking to you about you know as
you're right we're gonna do the agenda
schools we're gonna do the other things
that we've dreamed about within the
Samuel leach foundation we're going to
achieve these things there's a delay but
there isn't a teach you know and there
may be a delay but there's not going to
be a postponement in the sense or more
cancellation of what we're gonna do it
it's just that you like yeah that's
really powerful and I think it does test
you because when you're worried about I
mean certain certain staff it's very
very easy to panic mode as a business
owner and to just let go and to pull the
plug on things and to really lose focus
you know just to give you another
example Samuel that you know Ulysses may
not you know I run a festival of down
south each year called Big Joe stay on
there's back
7,000 people go to that and that's in
May we've had to pull the plug
well all the effects of that from
organizations staff and refunding
tickets there's no way we can do it this
year has been an absolute major headache
and nightmare you know and I'm still
against some of your people if they're
going I've got major headaches but
there's always a way through we've just
got to allow our creativity and we've
been furloughed people we've gone to
people and actually it's not going bust
and it will be on next year but we've
had to be really creative and again if
we keep our mental state right we can
keep being creative yeah that's great
what do you think some of the some of
the lessons doing this have been some of
the I mean you say about incubation and
learning growing through it what do you
think some of the key lessons have been
that you found personally or all the
people that you advise people the church
I think for me personally I've said this
to a number of people and I think the
word rush and the practice of rush has
really challenged me I'm always a man in
a rush and with this situation it's
taken the rush out of it and then taking
the rush out of it I've been able to
identify again the importance and the
urgent mm-hmm and I think sometimes when
we're in a rush we do the urgent but we
don't do the important and being able to
be at home I've got to be honest though
just those pauses those taught to think
has really helped me realize my again to
do the important and not just the urgent
and not be driven by the Russian urgent
and to be honest I don't want to go back
to that when we come through this my new
normal will be I really don't want to go
back to the rush and the urgent only
that's one of the lessons I can really
relate to that because normally in life
you've got so many people throwing
things at you urge them and they take
your focus but that's not really
happening now no one's there's there's
no one's throwing anything it's just a
case of okay I've got time what am I
going to focus on what am I gonna choose
to do in terms of helping charity
supporting communities to point other
people what were the best things to do
how can one go about supporting people
whether it be the community individuals
in country in this time those business
people are prospering at the moment that
want to maybe give or give them the time
people I mean first of all yeah first of
all there are a lot of good charities
doing a lot of good work in every city
and town in this nation right now you
know food banks are one of them
but there's many others and you know I
gave the example my daughter collecting
food I mean people could do that they
could donate money to food bank and all
of them are registered charities or they
could buy some Goods and donate them I
think you know we haven't got to create
something new in this season in
charities we've got to help those who
are already experienced in doing it and
you know in our own City we've just been
charged by the council for example to
make sure that we can feed thousands I
mean we're looking even if up to ten
thousand a week and the council have
given us some money for that but they've
got the infrastructure but we are and
also the council something your
listeners may not know this but none of
the public sector workers well very few
can be furloughed so they're paid full
but some of the work is limited so they
the Council of people honest and lentes
workers so we can set up food banks
across the city because a lot of the
volunteers were older volunteers and
because they're in the vulnerable group
they all disappeared when the government
had spent 12 weeks in isolation so we
lost a whole volunteer Bank but now
we're getting furloughed people
volunteering so we've got furloughed
people that are volunteering we've got
business people are volunteering and
time becomes more precious than money
dare I say so people who give their
money but if they've got some time you
that's become the precious commodity as
well volunteers packing up care packages
packing up lunches for children who have
free school meals but now there's no
schools cooking hmm and you know there's
a lot of vulnerable families out there
but there's a lot of good charity so I'd
encourage your listeners again to find
out what charities are really cutting it
in their area and although donate that
time or their money and get them a
mental to support because they're doing
a great work yeah that's good I mean
I'll say well I've got you on the call
cuz not as much as you talk about but
when I was starting out in business I
had this or guilt complex a little bit
around I should be doing more I should
be helping
I should be and it was this almost
pulling of do I want to make money and
be a business person or do I want to
actually be more involved in my church
getting involved charities and I split
my time between the two for the first
sort of few years of being in business
and it was just as niggling and then I
realized actually my time is better
spent working on my business and then
don't just being generous and giving
money because my time being spent
helping the homeless on the streets and
stuff awesome I shouldn't do that
but actually I didn't feel it was as
effective I thought I was more I was
gonna make more of an impact actually
focusing on making money and be generous
with it what do you think about that
well it's a great question and you might
not like the answer to this one I'm
gonna give it you anyway and your
listeners will be pleased and well I
think first and foremost every one of us
needs to go to the zone so we've got the
skill to do whether it you know and I
think you know you definitely have the
skill to make money Samuel you have the
skill in property so I think you know
that's the right zone but challenge the
successful people are is to remember
those promises they made themselves and
they didn't have much mmm
because the point is you know like I
said to one very successful businessman
just recently I said your challenge
isn't how much you give it's how much
you keep and I think you know we have to
you know have people around us at
challenges we have to have people around
that don't just agree with us all the
time successful people I'm on about and
the Bible talks about iron sharpening
iron when that happens there's some
spots so there's also gonna be a bit of
disagreement but I think it's healthy
for people like you so have people that
challenge you and so that what you say I
want to be generous that people say what
do you mean to them hmm you know because
generosity is very subjective as well
someone could say you know I'm a
millionaire not just give a thousand
pounds somewhere but that's that's not
an equal sacrifice to a single parent
who's just give a hundred pounds
somewhere there's certainly next to
nothing yeah so the point is never the
amount is to sacrifice yeah and of
course as we get more resources we've
got to not be challenged by the zeros we
got to be challenged by the sacrifice
yeah and we've got to remember where we
came from and so I think you know it's
really important that you know
successful people to give back to
society and many do and you do too I
know that but it's actually they become
a river and not a reservoir
you know look how much I've got look
there's nothing we need to be
embarrassed about in having nice cars
nice houses someone once said to me the
problem isn't what we've got is what's
got us yeah and I think giving challenge
is what has caused a quote that I use
quite a lot which which came from you is
you said everything on this earth is
leasehold we don't know we just hope we
just hold it and what do you mean by
that well I think I think I think that's
true I think as a Christian and and
somebody loves God I believe that you
know one day many years I gave my life
to God which meant you know everything I
am everything I own is his he's the
giver of all things to me now I know I
work I know I earn but he gives me
health you know he gives me energy I
believe he gives me favor and
opportunity you know in business and in
life I really believe that I believe
that my my days are ordered by the Lord
so in that I have a responsibility that
when I gave my life to God I then gave
everything I own to God and he gave back
to me - Stuart those things so in many
ways you know as Stuart is someone who
steward someone else's property I gonna
look after it and I believe that God
owns everything I have and so I'm a
lease holder and he's the freeholder and
one day he's been asked me and say guy
what did you do with what I gave you
and I need to answer to that yeah and I
believe that every human being in one
way or another with eternity in mind
maybe not on this earth some will have
to give an answer but on in eternity
every one will give an answer and the
question would be what did you do with
what I gave you and that can be little
or much and I want to have as best a
conscience I can that I was generous and
I didn't just keep I gave but there's no
embarrassment of people having it's just
making sure that we were we were a flow
of blessing we're not just people to
just keep yeah that's so good and I
think as well anyone listening to this I
think it's really important when you
become successful to have people around
you whether it's you and you're in a
church and your pastor or you might not
be Christian you might not be in a
church but to have people around you
that can hold you to account that can
speak into your life they keep you
grounded interesting thing about Gary is
that there are you kind of I mean when
we met I was already doing all right and
property and I was doing I was doing
pretty well but nothing like to the
extent that I am now so you kind of
helped me and supported me on my journey
up but then also on me account and keep
you grounded and level help you've kind
of been yeah and you know keeping your
ground it isn't to keep you down you
have to actually guide you're flying it
you know one sweats in a glider and I
was put in the front but the pilot was
behind me so like you know I could look
like I was driving but it was the pilot
behind me and it was really steering the
glider
and I think sometimes we gonna be like
that we may be in the front seen the
whole view but we've got to understand
that certainly it's Christian that God's
the ones controlling the deal and he
sees the bigger view than we do and I
think keeping you grounded he's never to
keep anyone down and you know I want to
say you know those who are not
Christians listening to this you know we
all have a moral compass it's come from
somewhere and we've just got to be kind
of like and having tegrity to that moral
compass and not be swayed by you know
when we've got money we now live
differently I know we can be blessed but
just make sure what he's ruling us
because there is a world out there but I
believe we all have a responsibility to
those who have resources and I do
believe there's a responsibility to
share as well as to be blessed ourselves
yeah no square wasn't be my working with
me then for the last of seven years some
you've been my hardy student I've ever
had I know you took Academy but man the
Academy that you
on ya your honor those that I've had to
as a as a teacher kind of really lose
sleep over you know what Samuel the
heart in you is great your enthusiasm is
infectious you're an incredibly positive
person and I think you know it's guiding
that power and that energy so that it
doesn't go off on a tangent but it
really achieves all that you want it to
achieve and so for me I don't have to
get the engine side with you I just have
to try and sometimes kind of pull you
into the lay-by and have a chat or cut
and then get you back on the motorway
you know what I mean so at least you're
moving there's too many people that Park
a ship in the harbor and never sail you
definitely want to be on the high sea
sailing and I like that about you yeah
thanks man but listen I'm really
grateful thanks for coming on me it's
been a very different type of podcast
today but I'm sure people have gleaned a
lot of information if people want to
contact you or who visit you at the
church once lockdowns over I'll leave a
link in the description with your my
website and stuff people can get in
touch with it like so if they need to if
they need a little bear guidance in
their life like like I need a little bit
guidance in my life so I know thanks so
much and I love thank you virtually on
Sunday thanks Sammy for having me on
it's been great all good chatting with
you